all right everybody welcome back to
another actually a very special episode
right now of I got this piece of [ __ ]
here with me so this is get right to it
ladies and gentle welcome to the podcast
mr. mr. Bobby Lee okay you want some
singing Mike
[Applause]
guys you're actually terrible okay first
of all this is not watching at home this
a real break I don't even know where you
get this at some party shop in [ __ ]
Tijuana yeah yeah what is this it's
exactly what you think it is it's a
thing it's a it's a piece of paper with
a brick wall on it yeah it looks nice
though that's what I'm saying when I
look at it on camera yeah exposed brick
and I come in here and it's like [ __ ]
ghetto dude look at this thing yeah okay
okay I know I don't want to face yet
here's another thing about these these
are your best headshots no no this is a
some fanart oh Willy Purdue made that
for me any jobs Berg you know that's
just from know I'm dying up here it's
light and then I was in a movie and then
the set they made this and I was like oh
wow that's so incredible it looks real
but I didn't really catch that fish yeah
you just look like here we go
what do you mean I'm just the truth
isn't that you could just tell by this
on this photo is that this when God made
you
uh-huh he was having a day really you
know you know who he made on that day
you know who he made on that day he made
you on that day too you know so
absorbent hired when's your birthday you
know
March 12th yet no we were made in
different days yeah but you're older
than me so he was already suffering from
the year a year earlier when he made you
you know no move up a little bit you're
gonna be like I mean whatever it doesn't
matter
start it we're starting let's talk about
how you lied to me about your your sick
uncle you know I almost called Steve to
be like Steve I'm so sorry to hear about
your uncle how can I say this I didn't
lie
oh no no Bobby you lied okay why what
did I say okay you lied what did I say
all right you just I said my favorite
uncle died withholding specifics is
still a lie that's not yes it is you
mind you I did not like I said
listen I said that my favorite uncle had
died yeah yeah and you go I'm sorry
the implication is that your uncle you
made them that you made that an
assumption
do you say oh my god you made that it's
not really the worst this is interesting
because I never been to your place
before I know and now we're like we're
friends now like 100% you've had you've
had my brother and Pikachu here before
me I I don't think so Pikachu has ever
been here yeah they do come and then uh
cuz we always go to look your thing like
you know you're anyways to start it what
are we doing here what are we doing here
for what we're doing here just because
this is the original podcast that it
should have been you gonna bring that up
again
it's okay no but we're gonna talk about
let's have a special episode talking all
about Game of Thrones yeah you know we
need to talk about Game of Thrones in
this final debauchery of the season that
they did you know I just I feel like
they made a really important show that
captivated the nation for like seven
years and the nature called it in it's a
cultural phenomenon for sure I when
people say I will refuse to watch it and
I go why I don't want to pay for HBO or
I'm I don't like dragons Yeah right it's
like dudes don't get it it's like it's
like living in the late 70s yeah and
someone saying I saw Star Wars and
you're like yeah I refuse yeah it's a
cultural thing you just do it yeah I
totally agree and even if you did you
even read the books of course you didn't
read the books I don't think I've ever
read a book right so you don't even I've
started to read the books when the show
first came on and I was looking at the
what he called it that the show at the
same time and for a while season one it
was very close to the book it was like
amazing how they were following then
they just veered off at a certain point
is embedded because the guy didn't
finish it well no no I'm talking about
in even in season one I'm sorry like it
did in the show kind of veered a little
bit and then I stopped reading the books
because I was like I like where the show
is going yeah well you can't really you
know reading something you know a book
you sometimes it doesn't translate
completely to show it can it can but the
book a lot of times the books are better
this is one of the rare times that I
felt like the show was just like doing
something great but I don't know me I
just say about movies your body is in a
movie mature that wait what are you the
last Jedi oh I was in the last Jedi you
are okay do you remember when I was in
the - yeah right you were in the new one
could you really don't know the last gen
a is the new Nathan third one that just
that's coming out Oh gotcha good right
is the struggle did you know got you
guys is the second movie that you had
the Asian lady was in saying what it was
you right but you're in it as well you
just shave your mustard what you are
what am i when Luke got the milk that's
not fun the creature is so not funny
your buddy of that body you don't have
that body okay you know who you are
you already you're the lady that runs
the casino temple you know the temple
yeah the lady with the big head yeah you
know who likes to [ __ ] walkies that's
you
oh you mean the one that was in the
first one as well yeah a little CGI
character yeah I'm fine with that issue
cuz you don't your character it's just a
[ __ ] see moose the side of a clean
she's got a little bit she's just like
squeezing out yeah you do you feel
better about insulting me does that make
you feel good somehow it's so funny that
you say something like that because I'm
not insulting you I am just saying
things that pop into my mind right that
I we could get it out could it be
possible that they are insults they
could be but I just feel like you're a
grown-up and you can handle it oh my god
let's go to back to Game of Thrones you
have a great body I feel good why would
I did I ask you to say that no I'm just
saying it's like I just think you ain't
no Brad Pitt bro okay but you think
you're like I never said I was well you
ain't no Ken Jeong you know what I mean
so now you want to get personal
what elawar I love it you're right I am
NOT that much more talented you know
you're like somewhere between Ken Jeong
that fan it's somewhere really really
you're somewhere between okay successful
yeah cool and long run right okay and I
don't know Delroy Lindo just reach in
now you know all right let's go to UM
Game of Thrones are you like here's like
if Steve Byrne had a baby
we're good we're not doing anyone before
here my feelings you lied to me about
not coming to the podcast compared you
come in and compare me to like a sea
moose and then and then you talk about
my brick wall right I say one thing
you're right my bad from that let's just
start from the wars wasn't good okay
we can see Game of Thrones Season eight
do you want to talk about the earlier
seasons at all the build-up and leading
into it because I felt like they did a
great job letting us wait for this like
you know this night King they just
didn't answer any questions that's the
thing that pisses me off nothing was
answered yeah what pisses me off the
most is is that they should have done
you like listen you've been given us 10
episodes yes you know a year can you at
least do that I think that would have
solved a lot because if you added four
new episodes
you could build Daenerys 'iz fall from
grace yeah yeah a little bit better yeah
I think the night King stuff that wore
the long night two or three extra
episodes there are certain things in it
that was just not explained yeah and but
then at the same time I want to defend
the show by saying yeah I know that it's
with the kind of budget that you have
with the expectations with it's just a
huge that's a huge thing tried I don't
think they try of course they try you
know I don't think they did I don't
think they wanted to do the show anymore
I think the creators of the show were
like how they get a gig checked out so I
think I wish they would have just been
like I don't want did let's
we're not gonna have a last season that
have been better than doing like a
half-assed season yeah but if you think
about it though it's um you know the
complaints are valid but you know the
last very last episode there were
moments where I went oh well that's
because the one before it was so [ __ ] oh
my god that was not good you did that
one first worthy they started off great
I thought the first three episodes were
pretty good good build-up you know even
going into the battle yeah I thought
that the long night that episode the
third episode was very good it was dark
yeah we are quite a few times actually
like three times I got chills yeah yeah
a couple of times yeah
the episode after that the after
aftermath was okay too I don't want to
give me an episode for yet the one after
the long night where they do that little
funeral thing outside right opening was
granny and they liked the fair I thought
it was okay yeah but it ended but then
it got dumb when like she's going first
for her dragon dies okay because they're
just kind of like they're just kind of
like lazily flying over to King's
Landing like oh let's go see what's
going on here also that dragon was hit a
couple of times riot right well I don't
like five times here's what I don't like
is is that you make dragons seem so
vulnerable and weak yeah in that
specific incident yeah where it's just
flying by okay maybe gets hit by one
yeah but it just seems like it could
just get destroyed yeah too easy yeah
and then in the last one just the fifth
one I mean yeah it's killing it like
nothing can touch it even the first
dragon died pretty easy yeah I know it's
the night king or whatever night king
power but this [ __ ] wasn't using an
arrow through Olympics yeah you know the
Western Westfield Olympics whoever he
[ __ ] threw the [ __ ] and like killed
it that's right yeah yeah me either
like how did why didn't he just crush
Aria by the way if he's that strong I
don't understand the power dynamics put
him in well he could throw a spear
[ __ ] practically you know I know that
that whole thing when he grabbed Aria
riot when she was jumping on yeah
his back yeah was more like listen if
I'm the night King right and some little
girl is trying to kill me I would have
done the same thing like you want that
moment of like hey [ __ ] what whatcha
doing
right yeah that's what he wanted oh yes
he could have killed her right away
yeah just squished her [ __ ] Wooster but
he needed that like you know me hey he's
gone through all that they've been
walking for seven years I mean at a
certain point it's like are you don't
you tired of all this [ __ ]
yeah we hear but I have a problem I
don't have a problem with that I have a
problem with the whole what is what do
you do why are you doing this you know
is it just a conquer the world like they
seem to be doing okay because they were
like they were there were fan theories
and like for instance that the White
Walkers had built the wall themselves
just to keep them away from humans
that's not true I'm just saying that
there were other theory like I know for
me just we want to conquer the world
yeah and that in it in itself it's not
enough it's not enough for me that's not
enough for me either
yeah and I didn't understand like all
the things that they didn't explain why
was brand so important to get why well
because he is he's the Internet yeah
well that's everything all the
information just didn't get like what
was like the point of trying to get him
so bad that this all this because he's
the memories of humans just didn't make
any sense to me think that makes [ __ ]
explain that just so annoying to me yeah
you don't care I do care I mean that
wasn't the thing that that's not one of
the things that rattles me what rattles
you a lot will go that's over here
[ __ ] um a lot here's a thing is
when remember the episode were the kids
on the wall yeah they made that symbol
with your arms right yeah and then there
are other incidences where they show
that symbol where the light king is
coming
like in the very first episode even they
do it with the with with the body part
yes right and the very first episode yes
um what is that I know you like could
choke you know I mean we'll just know
what is the context of that and why is
that important
yeah I I know you we know we don't long
I don't I don't understand
yeah and there um where's Arya going
giant China
where's she going she's looking for
gooks because you think we don't know
what's out there I got that's worth you
know that's spices and stuff are there
something else I don't understand about
like the depth of like how big is this
world that they live on like if it were
earth where is Westeros where are the
Seven Kingdoms you don't I mean I always
assume it's they know I always always
assume it's England okay all right but
it's not that big
what I'm trying to say is like all this
and all these people the north and all
this [ __ ] how actually big is it if
there's like an iron company who they're
a whole other place I think a map wise
if you want to refer it to earth mm-hmm
I think it's a earth right I don't know
I think I always felt like it was not
just even England but maybe more spane
oh right and that the the golden company
are from even further solid Middle East
right I got you guys and then that the
north is I slowly you're like they're
over there and like their Africa yeah
yeah yeah and then and then the North is
like Scotland or whatever oh you don't
know I don't know but the depth of the
place that I think she where she's going
is like what Magellan did was going to
view us like I don't know work bring
Typhoid Mary yeah yeah she's gonna bring
blankets yeah people think of people's
smallpox yeah it just feels like that I
don't know I just I just didn't I just
feel like just the main thing when you
would told me that they could have done
10 episodes and they chose to do six
that's what I heard that like they
wanted to do ten
and I totally understand why just think
the character development how about this
what is the point of John Snow
the Lord of Light bringing him back to
life what is the point of that and what
is the point of him being a Targaryen
what why tell us all that and go through
all that why make this this big secret
and then all of a sudden it's just like
he's just with the wildlings they do a
lot of they do a lot of things in the
show that in retrospect is annoying like
I'll give you an example the season
before when Daenerys and Jon Snow make
love on the boat yeah there was a scene
where Tyrion is like looking at the door
and he's like in the shadows in the
background they kind of ended the
episode that way were he like they made
it seem like there's something going on
where Tyrion is like plotting and
squatting and scheming and that he is
but then it just turns out he was just
watching them yeah he just like they
made it seem like though that this is
something that's gonna come into play
yeah I believe that they didn't know
what they were doing I think that like
they went into season eight writers room
and they were just like what do you
think we should do I don't think there
was a plan and I think they had an
arguments and they were like let's give
it to Brian you know no I think they
knew Aria was gonna kill the night king
okay like in season four okay I think
okay okay Brian was m.i.a
for like I three full season I think
[ __ ] gone but think about why
now they knew that he was gonna be the
king of it all right no they did but
they just listened to my theory okay is
is that so it could it be like I just
not even put on put him on you know I
mean it for a couple episodes like
Gendry Gendry like there's certain got
people we've never seen again
yeah right but maybe that's why they did
it
I had to confuse us I just think that
they didn't know that's who think it got
too big for them and I think they
started to believe the hype that they
they created a great show and they
thought that it was just them that you
know that it didn't all the moving parts
and everything weren't a part of it I
think they want to start star wars right
you know they they're doing the new Star
Wars Oh HBO know all these people yeah
Weiss and yeah
oh god I hope not they are well yeah so
this one can ruin that too look at it
that way I'm sorry
we already got no don't look at it that
way they're already ruining stuff they
gave us eight seasons or seven seas okay
all right just listen
probably one of the best entertainment
you've ever seen okay the red wedding
you know there was a episode called um
whatever it's called home oh yeah I know
I do not get it and then they did um you
know a lot of great great episode yeah
the way they killed people that you
didn't explain so I mean they dropped
the ball a little bit at the end a
little bit okay how about this episode
for that you say you like I like they're
outside this wall and she's standing
there yeah with like 15 dudes with no
dicks and her little dwarf and a dragon
that's like injured in the back and
they're standing in front of this wall
and Cersei has all of these [ __ ]
arrows and [ __ ] okay why didn't she just
kill them right there why cut off this
chicks head and not just kill everybody
right there and end this [ __ ] that's so
dumb what you're saying to me why is it
dumb because you've never been in a war
oh and so you're Genghis Khan all of a
sudden okay we know if you know this but
like what great-grandparents oh my god
we're part of the royal royalty of Korea
uh-huh
and they had they were they were also on
my world too you were building the wall
between South but when you because we've
talked about this before is you know in
you know when you like in the brother
the bastards war uh-huh you know Ramsay
and his crew and Sons on John they came
at met in the center of the field and
then ago she ate Nikki in that and those
circe she doesn't know blew up her own
people she don't give a [ __ ] about none
that's part of the rule
no I and then here's the thing okay with
it your whole thing is a butt in the air
all these like scorpions yeah to kill
yeah but none of those guys were like
behind a scorpion like they were ready
to go no no they were maybe feel like if
one guy who slowly went behind one of
those things this is what the drug
wonder nobody dragon was weighing about
named I I know I drop you would know he
would have seen he would have seen if
you know that dragon could have just
wrecked a whole [ __ ] [ __ ] right
that's what it was yeah yeah yeah okay
do you think you think it's a rule let
me ask you this what's that dragons name
drug on just then why does she always
say when she's about to burn people she
she always says jerk heiress because
that's me that means fire did that mean
what kill fire yeah so it doesn't
understand English at that point all of
a sudden sometimes it does understand
also those dragons they feel your heart
they feel your heart yeah so she in her
heart she just you know they're
connected you know I feel like that
there's something you have to love it
okay it would have to be telepathy you
know what I mean oh I just don't I just
don't think that she would have if
you're gonna have the CGI just have the
whole unsullied army outside not 17 mm
it just doesn't it just visually I don't
like somebody filmmaking they were doing
this should have a photo of just your
dick the ugly truth that you feel better
now feels good but you just have to like
put an insult in it every 15 minutes
just it feels so good just to do that
just to feel normal I guess
yeah yeah I you know and here's another
thing about the show is that you just
there's nothing we can do about it I
know you know like a lost Yugi or watch
lost yeah oh did I but I checked out
yeah I mean when were that one where
they went back in time you know in the
70s I was out I still watched no no I
was out and I would watch it like every
episode like you know when I was out
meeting you when I was out on lost this
smoke monster because when the smoke
monster came that turned it into that
turn
in a magic science fiction and then I
was out cuz up to that point you were
like you didn't really know what this
was about so you didn't have that you
didn't your brain didn't attach to any
sort of concept yet but when that came
it was like oh well this is all
make-believe now like they they you know
yeah and I was out after that yeah you
know what I loved about lost is that on
network television like cuz that pilot
was great who's incredible I was really
good look I had never seen that kind of
production yeah it was just it was just
fun to watch but in many ways the game
of thrones did what they did yeah but at
the same time though they they had the
ability cuz here's a story that they
know was how it's gonna end you would
think they'd go this person is gonna end
up on the Iron Throne and this is why
and we're gonna show you why that
happened and I just think filmmaking
wise they didn't do a good job like how
many times did you think people were
dead like in that fight the night king
fight it's like here's like a hundred
dead people surrounding bran of ptarth
whatever you know and then all of a
sudden
Yoshi's gonna die yeah the next scene Oh
didn't die I'm sorry
also Sam would die would it died the
first yeah yeah he was the first wave he
would have been dead yeah he would have
tripped yeah like 15 dudes would eat
that and then same thing with Jon Snow
it's like here's the dragon and all
these jobs I was gonna die oh no he's
still alive he got away and so that to
me is a filmmaking issue and the same
thing in the last episode here's Arya
going through the city here's a building
and they show the building like it's her
perspective it's about to fall on her
yeah Oh Arya is dead that's not anything
everybody's gonna be mad no oh she's not
dead it was wall of fire oh she's dead
oh [ __ ] she's not dead they also you
know the lady Mormont the girl with the
the you know the little girl I loved her
I loved her too she's amazing really
great actress really great really I just
love that character but she had one of
the most gruesome deaths so yeah she
just looks all peaceful her face even
mangled oh she's in the are issues in
the armed
her brother lover her lover you know
nummy right she has her baby still her
TomTom yeah
and she's laying there peacefully no way
no way no way she should mean that
little girl gets caught every bone yeah
crushed inside her body yeah all right
and yet she still you know I mean has
enough if she kills a giant yeah
here's another thing is brand going
beyond you're a good man yeah right
how about this fee on Aria will be here
in 12 seconds wait out waited out
because you know why why Fiat still
killed his brother you know I mean the
unkilled woo see it's because of Theon
that the other loop start boy is dead
remember there was two of them yes yes
he redeemed himself but at the same time
he's got to die
no because I feel like his first of all
what a great character our office one of
the probably you know that's how you're
supposed to do it was great yeah yeah
it's supposed to be like you know Jamie
could have had a good character arc too
but it didn't it didn't turn out that we
didn't turn out that way but but Theon
like wow what what a character and you
know he branched a window but it's fine
yeah but how about this how about this
man you know are there any female riders
on this show I don't think so
I'd have to look and see well I don't
understand why here's a chick who the
guy comes she has sex for the first time
with him who you know
Jaime and Brienne right and then he
leaves for his sister and basically
turns on everyone and this [ __ ] is
writing about him in a book like get the
[ __ ] out of here she would have hated if
it was instrument would have blocked him
away they're like revenge porn are you
know Namita something yeah like that if
I was her yeah I would open that buck up
yeah and
what does to okay doc you know to me
yeah yeah doesn't deserve these [ __ ]
[ __ ] right and good [ __ ] about him for
right but you know what dude you
remember your first dick fry it was your
mom don't say that about my mom you
think mom you wanna bring mom's into it
oh my god okay let me talk about your
mom no please talk about my mom no I
love her yeah look at you I love your
mom she's coming home right yeah okay
good your mom was but your mom was great
and stole ours too let's talk about your
mom you didn't know your mom was Yoda
stunt double I just said how many times
that the war yeah
oh that's it get everything out of all
my mom cuz I don't wanna talk about your
mom's your mom's sick oh really gonna
bring that up that's not even funny see
how you are that's what I'm saying I'm
warning you
oh you're warning me yeah a week ago you
want to go I drove all the way to Culver
City yeah whatever
oh yeah we times I've driven for you I
don't know dude I just think the font
like I said the final episode was just
like again Jamie Jamie a nurse is the
sister should have got it good
just let ru kill her you know I don't
know why they didn't just let are you
fine I thought are you was you know when
she was by herself yeah that's the time
like the you know would have been great
if like his little should have happened
she's those Queens now cuz her [ __ ]
guy is gone the [ __ ] monster guide
that you know which I thought he should
have looked way worse underneath the
helmet when he took his helmet off I was
like why have you been wearing a helmet
you mean the mountain his eyes are
bloodshot red I know but his face was
like you know like yours you didn't mean
it was round you're gonna me your face
was the prototype further for the for
the Hound I'm just saying I thought his
face was more mangled and beat up and
like it like a hodgepodge put together
but you like Frankenstein or something
but it looked actually I like your mom's
[ __ ]
I had to get that out I had to get that
out oh yeah they shoot him it did you
look CGI'd your mom's [ __ ] onto his
face ah here we go you can feel better
about yeah and it's like you know I mean
it's got kind of like her lips are so
big uh-huh they could be like sort of
like a predator kind of a thing yeah
well I mean I should have looked like
that IMAX
you're so stupid
yeah okay so then are anyways so she's
walking by herself it would have been
nice if Aria comes okay and she's like
I'm gonna kill you
but then Jamie comes and Jamie and Aria
fight you get what I'm saying you ride
that would have been better yeah yeah I
mean or I thought the my Podrick brand
idea I like when they did the council
dinner you're all right dinner but that
meeting experience okay we get to that
later that's that's a different ending
to the show I'm so we're talking about
right now what should have happened to
Cersei and Jaime cuz that's a different
point I like what you're about to say
okay but let's just go with this right
let's go what's okay defective because
this is what happened you know the Queen
and Jaime they they get were trouble on
them and apparently the rocks don't hit
their face which is [ __ ] ridiculous
like how is he pulling rocks away at the
end and they're just laying there like
right like what yeah you know they were
hugging and then rocks came the skull
should have been crushed that had been a
more reason for him to cry like that to
not just because they're dead but to see
what happened to them yeah it was sexy
he also had his arm around her body
protecting the baby yes yeah a peaceful
death yeah what I would have done is you
know when you're on Greyjoy was fighting
Jaime you know and then he gets stabbed
a couple of times and I'd and then you
know he gets your on he walks away to go
back into that cave to go back in so try
to get into fine sir yeah Cersei and
then he finds Cersei down in that place
and then it turns out to be Arya because
she made wore the mask she kills Cersei
in a brutal way and she turns around and
then Jamie gets there hmm maybe that
but that sounds more exciting than what
[ __ ] actually happened yeah I just
don't get the point of like letting her
get out like that and here's something
else just what I don't like about the
last season is people went against their
character
so here's Cersei who's been like the
women in the show they write them is
just like calculating smart evil like
you know what I mean like they need a
there ten steps ahead why would this
[ __ ] be standing in a balcony watching
the whole city burn and not do anything
like why would she think that oh all of
a sudden she's like the red cape is the
safest place all of a sudden now she's
an idiot
no [ __ ] way no way and why don't do
any of those scorpions at the [ __ ]
red keep what they don't think the
dragon can fly high and then come to the
city yeah okay it turns out the red
those scorpions don't work with that one
it doesn't even matter just logic yeah
you're right logic of it is like do they
think that like the dragon has to fly
low why wouldn't the dragon come flying
from the sky right to the red keep yeah
you're not gonna have scorpions on the
radio right right I didn't notice that
it's that's the kind of [ __ ] where I go
I I'm out this is just [ __ ] stupid
yeah you know and she wouldn't just be
standing there like that like oh this is
gonna she was calculating she made to
all the people in the city coming to the
red cape because she knew but she's all
subdued she's also losing it you could
just move up a little bit if you want to
get more mic action there you go perfect
like this yeah she was losing her mind
in Cersei wasn't losing her mind not at
any point where she losing her mind shed
logic the logic of the logic of her
going I'm not gonna help you know mm-hmm
with the war up north you know oh by the
way were you saying that okay here's
something else I think should happen
sorry to cut you off but this is another
thing that should have happened
immediately after the night king wore
the [ __ ] Lannister army should have
been at the gates of Winterfell like oh
thanks for doing that we're here and
then take over these [ __ ] why
because that was the whole point was
whoever's left will defeat because they
would have like depleted each other
because if you're smart too if you they
told you what happens with the night
king with the dead people you're not
gonna wait for the for the dead because
in all the people are kings like that's
making the assumption though that's
making the assumption that the people in
the north are gonna win right
no no what she was saying whoever wins
we might have enough forces left yep
gonna risk the fact that if the night
King won but they should have been ready
for it man they should have been ready
for they they don't have to be right
there that could be five miles away I
know but still easy outs it's still
easier to protect yourself in it with in
a cast apparently not okay apparently
not because look what happened you know
I mean I just think that I they went
against character with us with all the
only character the only two characters
that really female characters that
stayed on message was like Sansa Sansa
from the beginning was like nah the
north we she was always about protecting
the north and all her decisions were
about that so I got her right Aria - how
are you - oh yeah that's I'm saying Aria
was like she was about her she wanted to
get revenge the the Hound have convinced
her that hey you don't want to be like
me which was a beautiful moment that
wasn't so great when he like go home
girl you don't want to be like me I
thought that was beautiful yeah you know
I mean I cried during this yeah yeah
yeah that was a good part but like I
just don't understand why the Dragon
Queen why Danny and Cersei all of a
sudden of a cuckoo cuckoo like out of
nowhere yeah I just I just I didn't buy
it man here's another thing I wanted to
happen is after the episode before the
third one you know when they're getting
ready for them to attack yeah that
because you didn't see the night king
that episode yeah yeah yeah right
yeah there was a theory that the night
King was attacking King's Landing at the
same time although would've been great
but that would have surprised Jaime did
they walk real slow it takes them seven
years to get like you know a mile I mean
we don't know how long it is it was a
long time you sure I'm sure how far away
is the black castle to Winterfell but
let's just suppose
he has a dragon right maybe he why
didn't he do that why didn't he do what
[ __ ] Danny did to the two kings land
that's what I'm saying why didn't he
come in on Winterfell on a dragon seems
like he could have done what a waste of
Dragon would never to Surprise them to
be do the misuse of dragons in this show
is just ridiculous yeah you know but
still at the end of the day what can we
do I know well I'm just saying this is a
thing they should have called us what do
you think we should do on our other
podcast episode you made a great point
about Star Wars
you said the dude from Star Wars should
[ __ ] bring real nerds in a room and
say hey this is what I'm thinking about
doing so we can go don't ever wouldn't
thank you for having us here yeah yeah
but what is your [ __ ] problem
I didn't know you knew Ken Burns's yeah
he's a documentary film a member it's
great I love her yeah yeah but I've seen
all of them I saw his World War two one
and Vietnam before the Vietnam one he
had made the documentary and then he
didn't release it right away he brought
in Vietnam vets from both sides
hmm from the American side and the
Vietnam side like generals and shed Wow
and she showed the documentary and he
goes give me notes so I'm singing right
so then they would give him notes and
then he would change the appropriate
thing look I wish they would have they
should have said okay going into season
eight yeah here's a focus group of
[ __ ] nerds and nerds yeah and just
like what do you guys want to know oh
then it would have been like okay we'll
try to answer that we'll try to answer
this and they just didn't do that dude
and look at all the holes in the story
okay yeah look character development
wise alright again Jon Snow wasted even
bran we don't know what the [ __ ] going
on with him I don't know the extent of
his power they started to show it with
the whole door and all that [ __ ] you
like oh this kid's gonna be something
and then nothing he's just said oh yeah
you would as I assume that his working
stuff would have like I thought that he
was gonna warg into a dragon or
something and do something with that
power that was like thank you amazing
yeah yeah you know being the yeah he
could mean why would you pick a hawk
when you the first time he remember the
first time he realized there was
something going on is when
um sanz's direwolf gets killed by Ned
Stark yeah yeah and then as soon as he
gets dot bran wakes up yeah that's when
he woke up from his coma zactly
and so you thought yourself oh [ __ ] how
about this brother this guy is gonna be
a like a powerful how about this
why did give brand the same scene 50
times here's the scene like Jamie comes
to him and he's like hey sorry about
throwing you out the window you are
where you're supposed to be okay
Greyjoy you know I'm sorry it's okay you
all were you're supposed to do I right
right like that was his line like every
time he had something to say
yeah he's like oh you what you know do
you want to be king why do you think I'm
here like it's like what yeah what are
you like a robot all of a sudden also he
said something in this year into the
season or what episode where he said to
somebody um I would be no use I mainly
only live in the past yeah something
like that
yeah and then you're like yeah what yeah
we want our King to be present god yeah
at the moment and then check out salsa
sauce it's like the Bobby Lee in there
and then in the relationship because
she's all like his dick doesn't work I'm
gonna do me like this uh yeah cuz that's
some fucked-up [ __ ] you would say about
your brother you know I mean I feel like
heaven be king and she's like whoa well
he can't have kids so why are you gonna
make him [ __ ] D railing him like what
a [ __ ] because I think that she's still
I think here's another thing is that if
John is the rightful heir right of the
throne uh-huh
Junie be the guy bro bro how about this
these this council is gonna make
decisions for the Seven Kingdoms they
seem like a bunch of [ __ ] idiots man
with all the things he did he went to
the [ __ ] he'd be on the wall to capture
one right to bring him back right oh he
came back to life how about this - yeah
well why doesn't he just say - like the
unsullied guy and everybody like yo bro
she burned down the whole city man I
would how about a baby carpet
yeah but you're really gonna like I know
you love your queen I know and she was
supposed to it's like it's like the
point to me is like why do people love
her because she was about justice she
was about overcoming like oppression and
tyranny and she became what she hated
and this [ __ ] doesn't understand
that no John did the right thing that
[ __ ] had to go yeah you know what I
mean like and I don't understand that
turn hey hey you know what you burn like
you burn a little bit of the city to
prove a point right you man in LA okay
maybe you burned a Compton Burbank just
fly to the red cape and burn that [ __ ]
down yeah
sperm that down yeah whole city that's
the thing is they were snapping to her
to justified to kill baby I don't get
the justification why isn't is so the
shift was so dramatic um I just I didn't
buy it man yeah that's the whole thing
is I didn't buy it yeah like how are you
burning down the whole city you know and
then all of a sudden again this dragon
all of a sudden is like the greatest
dragon in history finally figuring out
let's go sideways you know look even
grey worm though his turn
cuz the whole you know I get his turn
though no no no by the way I disagree I
get his turn you're a [ __ ] monster
you know people have been you know
you're you're you're been just a robot
your whole life your whole purpose in
life is just till I kill and be a
warrior
this chick gave him purpose and then he
fell in love you know and then and then
he watches his love get his head cut off
yeah but we're head cut off did you say
this or that he was a slave correct nice
life right so as a slave you know what
it feels to be oppressed yeah
and happy powerless and helpless yeah
because you don't have you know your
status okay or the the means even yeah
yeah for him to look at
you know I mean the dragon lady there
Danny and to go yeah burn everyone yeah
to me as a sex slave yeah that would not
occurred no but see to me but I think he
now moment no babies no I agree with you
but I'm saying in that moment when he
was looking at these other soldiers yeah
and then she did that in that moment I
get him being like this is the love of
my life but again not enough character
development for him to see how important
that relationship is for him again is
another drop the ball by the creators
and look look the problem I have with
this final season is the execution of it
and then just the lack of thoughtfulness
in like tying up these stories man yeah
you know I feel like there's some things
I wanted to see that didn't happen like
I say I think the King's Landing army
should have been ready
I think the Battle of the battle
shouldn't happen at King's Landing I
think about a final battle should have
happen at Winterfell you know I mean
even that I think that here's the thing
the show opens in the first season with
with White Walkers yeah yeah yeah cuz to
me there is nothing more terrifying
right then no idea that beyond death you
would think that that would be the final
by the way why have you seen black
summer on Netflix those are good
oh it's great what is it it's a zombie
movie it's Kosambi show this is all
black summer yeah yeah who's in it I
don't know the people they're in it but
it's a really great it's really great
how it's done they they'll go to like
different people's story during the
story it's all interconnected they'll
even go those and follow a zombie you'll
see a zombie story I mean it's great
anyway but go on how many episodes you
saw it's worth it it's totally worth it
I'm gonna start tonight yeah started you
know I don't really trust your
recommendation yes she do the witch was
amazing no it wasn't amazing stop stop
it okay you needed subtitles for that
[ __ ] movie right no oh yes you did do
you know why why cuz I understand the
English language oh my god you [ __ ]
idiot no you understand like mumble
language cause it sounded like your
grandma or something like how they were
now you go back to race in my [ __ ]
history Hey you just talk about my mom's
[ __ ] is like predator okay I come at
you okay so the whole series off with
this undead blue eyed monster right I
know you just said you just said move
forward man this is just so
uncomfortable okay because if you go
like this okay and don't like it I just
know things comfort no move forward move
the chair forward I'm working it out I'm
still working cuz you're leaning back so
move for the reference because you want
to lean back so move the chair forward
like yes there okay is that better for
you oh my god you're so this I'm sorry I
don't have look you know I know the
hiker barely budget no glad to be here
in the city but just move this like this
okay okay here's a that's enough
you you like black things like that in
your face I've never sucked a black dick
and it's crazy
I like that distinction I like that
distinction why you've never sucked a
black dick cuz you're racist I'm not
racist do you thing I'm racist no you're
not racist you're just a nobody real
beep do you think I am no I don't think
you're very people some people think I
am I why would a why do you think no no
you're not racist you're just not
thoughtful with your words so you just
say things and then you know how
sensitive people can be they pick up on
words when you use the words like black
or anything like that they think that
you are saying that because of that but
you're just using it as a description
you know yeah I mean I I say thing like
I like for instance I've had people say
people always say racial things to me
Ryan yeah you know you'll meet somebody
like after a show and some guy will come
up to me and just do like white some
older white man and do an Asian accent
okay now by the way what you're talking
about right now is our lack of empathy
for the Asian experience and I do think
that that's a real thing yeah I think
people don't think that they for some
reason people think Asians don't
feelings but we've always here's we've
never had a voice so um like back in you
know what drove me into doing stand-up
in the first place it's not is watching
Def Jam mm-hmm
because I would watch Def Jam and I
would see you know them just make fun of
it
do the Asian accent or anything or
anything no specific to you though so
that's what you who I saw that I would
watch and it would be not offensive but
like oh that's cool you can say whatever
you want but we don't have anyone
representing us right to defend us you
know so um you think that you're
defending your culture and race well
here's what you do cuz I've seen your
act I know can I say this though and I
defend my race by being funny you know
cuz it was such a war very fair with
Bobby is very there was a stereotype
even for an Asian yet Asians were
accidentally funny but not funny
purposely funny what who say because
people would say like other accents are
funny but they're not really you know
funny in terms of timing right but um I
think as long as like when I see you
know like when I see somebody like Jill
coy or somebody robbed a room it makes
me feel proud yeah that's all would you
like Joe counts solely as Asian though
he is Asian
got a little Latino I know you know he's
Filipino Filipino and he can't help it
yeah they don't count as Asian Pacific
Islands yeah I know Joe I'm just teasing
you okay nobody I think you're doing a
fine job I don't even talk about why not
you don't like talking about yourself
you don't like getting some praise this
is just as your own insecurity about
your act everything like that but Bobby
you are legitimately one of the funniest
human beings on and offstage I know but
you know somebody told me last night
where they're at a Netflix kind of a
dinner uh-huh
with the rock right and Chris D'Elia and
Ali Wong and everyone's invited aren't
able and these are supposed to be like
you know I mean the best relevant comics
yeah right it's a key
right there though what you just said
what relevant is different from like
being like the best or being really
funny or being like whatever it is yeah
but you know whenever there's like a
little supposed elite group yeah I've
never I've never been in my house right
so totally good you you you compare I
think I'm there I wasn't there either I
know
listen I'm I I stand by my comedy I
don't think anybody if we have a show
right now I don't care who's on the show
if I'm on the show nobody's gonna be
like that guy shouldn't be on the show
they're gonna be like damn that guy's
funny too
yeah that's that's how I feel yeah but
just because like you know you know
Netflix has decided to like here's the
people we're gonna push they don't
understand their own power
that's what does it pisses me off like
Netflix have the power to make anyone be
a star cuz they're trying all the time
they puttin out like here's a hundred
you know specials here's a hundred
three-minute special yeah yeah I mean
here's people we like and then they put
it out there and then they see what
happens but the fact that they're
passing over people who have been
working hard for like so long give me
that opportunity like why don't you put
me you know you've put it's not like a
it's a [ __ ] hard drive yeah when they
tell me they don't have space or like
hey we're like you know hey you go to
Kinko's go to Best Buy buy a hard drive
put my special on it connected to the
network the Netflix hard drive there's
enough [ __ ] space man yeah you know I
mean don't forget to just tell me you
don't think I'm funny just tell me you
don't like me but don't give me this
[ __ ] about space yeah the computer
but it also goes to my old fears of
because when I started doing the door in
in say in LA and in San Diego you know
you would see a lot of comics that were
older that never made it yeah that could
probably rattle off 200 names but that's
the nature of the business I know but
they're one of those people I know but
there is a fear that I will become Who I
am
Bobby you're gonna be on cancelled shows
for the rest of your life okay so don't
worry about it okay yeah you know that's
just the nature of this this business
man but you know what that insecurity
that you have
we both have hmm that's what drives us
to keep going to keep thinking that were
it's not we're not and that's what the
game of Thrones creators needed see the
Game of Thrones creators thought that
they were like oh we're Seinfeld we're
we're we're Eddie Murphy we're Richard
Pryor no [ __ ] yeah
you didn't make it you're not done but
could there be this idea that no matter
what they did that they would have
backlash no I disagree with you
completely because we've been following
the story they've been putting the
breadcrumbs of the things and it's like
yes I think tit like you know you know
what maybe maybe you're right I mean
maybe like even let's say John is denied
is the king at the end would have been
sat would it have been satisfying
because it would have been cuz that
would have been um lackluster because we
already assume yeah that's gonna happen
he's the rightful heir he's still alive
but he's been the number one on the call
sheet probably yeah yeah top three for
sure top three for sure yeah she's
number one
what's-her-face Daenerys is probably
number one in a Mormon College but
John's definitely number two to number
three how about but see like when he
killed three surprised when he killed
her on the kiss I thought that um can I
be honest with you that was a surprise
because it was little earlier on in the
show and I was I could just kill her I
swear I thought that was cool yeah I
agree yeah that was on message that was
unnecessary was on brand from their
Thrones you know when the dragon came
because Danny's dead yeah and him
turning to burn down the Iron Throne
yeah I thought that was dope - yeah that
was good I think there would have been a
cool scene there where he tries to burn
John but he can't because he is that's
what I thought Hungarian yeah that's
what I thought it was okay my version of
it would have been Danny needs to kill
him because he's always gonna be a
threat just like Arya said he's she's
you're gonna be a threat for the rest of
your life you can't you know and he did
he did like whatever he unis in her mind
betrayed him betrayed her and I thought
that she would is not gonna be the same
kind of scene John standing there and
then it would've been she would have
been Jack artists you know and then
and then John's like [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
yeah crazy that would have been a cool
Targaryen so that would have been cool
too
that was nice our I thought that was a
great moment with the dragon taking her
off and you know that that was a little
cool moment in the show the scene this I
really did like this the council scene
with Tyrion oh no okay all right
before that like why why is it every
time I come to my theory huh that you
want to start with I'm sorry go ahead go
why no because because you're missing
something right before that what is it
okay because you're talking about the
council seeing where they're sitting
there and they bring them out of jail no
okay you took at the end the very end oh
yeah all right go go I'm sorry
thought you were talking about something
else but I I think the show should have
ended with that what I think the show
should have ended them pan out and
they're discussing how to fix the
kingdom that would have been a great
ending to the show no all for me yeah I
would love that because we don't know
what happens at John or no no do that
[ __ ] first show John and then come there
at the end at the very end of the the
move that scene to the end well they're
like okay what are we gonna do no no
because III wanted the scene where
Tyrion is organizing the chairs right I
love that and then when that was great
no I did because when you saw the group
it was everyone we grew up with yeah
yeah
Davos Breanna was there hot rocks there
Braun is there mm-hmm
so that felt I get it's like the Lord of
the Rings scene yeah yeah
I seen where they at the third movie
they they did the whole thing where
everyone bow to the four hob you know me
and the Hobbit had eight endings that
one yeah that one was weird
yeah and then I remember but enough
Bilbo goes on the long voyage somewhere
or whatever that's the Aria moment right
that really is the Aria moment same
ending actually this is kind of a same
ending they're lazy that's what I'm
saying yes it lets Lord of the Rings
this the here's where I thought that it
would be cool to end uh-huh his so
Tyrians there and then Podrick brings in
brand via chair be chair they dragged in
and then he asked where the dragon is
right and they're like we don't know he
goes I'll try to go find him so they
he turns around and when Podrick is
leading him out to Michael Jackson
Thriller ending his eyes turned below
yeah yeah the he's the night king then
it goes Michael Jackson that is yeah Oh
humor me he's hugging the girl he turns
to the camera and his eyes are like a
[ __ ] beach Riya Riya he didn't like
that then now it was okay I wasn't with
ever him being the night king I just
wasn't with that you weren't I wish they
would explain how someone becomes a
night King that would have been nice to
know like what it looked like because he
was touched but he still has the dude's
hand imprinted on his forearm there's
some sort of connection maybe but maybe
no see the council meeting I thought you
were talking about was like when they
were outside I know which one you're
talking about see I think that like I
thought that that was crazy we just go
it's like three weeks later you know I
mean and then now like John's in jail
right you know to me and it's like
you're like okay what like what's
happening right here like you skipped a
lot of [ __ ] that happened how they find
out what so what did John do you want
you want to see Sons uh get the pigeon
message no no no no no just get the
penny he goes oh [ __ ]
Daenerys is dead check the sounds in
prison yeah and you want to see her get
on a horse no no check this out more
great episodes of being like now the
dragon queen is dead that would be chaos
in the nation man like you know first of
all what did John do he must have went
down him in like yeah killed her then
they like let's arrest him she could
have been like why would he tell is he
that honorable I guess he look yet a
dragon took she went she left with the
dragon know people saw no they didn't
know they didn't no one saw him kill her
no but people know somebody must have
seen him at least go that direction yeah
so so they're like the body last one bro
bro the body's gone bro the body's gone
she dragon flew off people saw the
dragon fly off oh yeah I would have
covered that blood with the snow or ash
or whatever yes a easy cleanup know what
she said I'm out she goes I'm going to
Baja
yeah why would the yeah
I just think that they just it was
laziness like how are we gonna get from
here to here they just said I let's just
do a three weeks later situation yeah I
just didn't like that
and it looked like it looked at sons and
said hey there's an army outside all the
went all of the winter all of the North
Army is outside so you killed John it's
gonna be a situation that's a lot of
tension a lot of buildup the unsullied
don't know that that army is coming and
they're just like they're not prepared
for another war you have a great you
have a great grain worm would have said
well they're gonna be war they'll be
there would have been a war okay never
to play you know what was a stupid
moment is when like Tyrion comes out
they got him and then the guy says I owe
so I guess you want to be king as if
they were gonna make him King he was in
jail and all of a sudden they're gonna
let the dwarf come out and be like if
they can do that they could get Jon Snow
why would the grey worm guy just be okay
with like okay everybody wins we'll go
get our island that is true it was a
weird like he kind of caved pretty
quickly yeah yeah yeah if he could cave
then he could be then he can have the
reasoning that Jon should be king I just
don't get right there was that bad
that's just bad filmmaking man it's bad
writing bad filmmaking and I just don't
get why we're like why they were allowed
to like be so lazy with this final
season it's just utter laziness
it's I'll tell you why it's not okay
this is just my opinion going could I
just tell you a give an example um a
little personal example oh god is when I
was on a show called animal practice
yeah where were you on the call sheet
you were a sixth the monkey was like
four or five right was it so your
proudest moment when the monkey let me
go to the singing mic I'm gonna my point
is dumb no it's not no no I honestly
when I was saying it uh-huh it's a dumb
point that when I point
got the monkey you didn't use brought up
the monkey you rip me apart and I just
decided to let it go but that show was
cancelled are you trying to compare
animal practice to no throne no on what
I would know I got to hear that now what
they're not even close to being yeah
similar you know ones you know low-budge
the other ones real yeah here's the
thing but my show runners were the Russo
brothers mhm and at the same time they
were slaughtered to direct Captain
America oh wow Silva war oh hey Joe I
know they did a great job and they did
all the adventure movies they're the
best Damascus but they were my bosses
and you could tell like because our show
wasn't doing well that they just kind of
but you weren't around anymore because
they had something else bigger that they
were doing so you know I think that the
two show runners for Game of Thrones
right had the Star Wars imagine I
disagree with you no man no no no why
because when they were making animal
practice okay there's a moment that they
know they're making animal practice
there's a moment they know that we're
making what is this by the way they're
making a god all if the [ __ ] is this
it's a wand okay no just say not you
don't say like an old African [ __ ]
anal dildo and this is why people think
you're racist there it is right there
and why is it African anal dildo this
symbol right here
which is that you know what that is what
that is the Deathly Hallows from Harry
Potter that's what that symbol is yeah
so just put it down sorry my bad anyone
is this imagine it that what is this I
got it I got a thing from this secure Oh
they're like publicist for the game and
they sent me all this [ __ ] so that's
from for the game it's a really great
game if you played Sakura oh I love oh
my god it's such a great game but like
Bobbie Duke I just finish go ahead okay
making game of thrones and making animal
practice is not the same feeling like
one you're making something beautiful
and great the other one you know you've
got I didn't wanna [ __ ] you monkeys I
imagine Bobbie imagine if the Russo
brothers have been lazy on the last
Avengers they're like we've been doing
this for 11 years we've made 22 movies
I'm kind of done with it and they would
have done some half-ass [ __ ] for the
last Avenger you're right that's what
the that's why I didn't want to finish
my [ __ ] thought you [ __ ] and I didn't
want you to I know and I finish it and
how you do this I'm sorry you just got
me excited you know I'm just passionate
about this thing I'm cutting you all
let's just wrap it up by saying this
okay is is that I could leave Bobby your
yeah we gotta wrap it up why what time
is it yes give it we've been doing we've
been talking a while this is great okay
but here's the thing
uh-huh I'm not done talking I just
wanted I don't want to talk about this
okay how did you I want to talk about
other things all right
okay at the end of the day it they did
give us great entertainment over eight
years agree
you probably one of my favorite shows of
all time yeah me too
I'm gonna deeply miss it yeah it really
was something that my girlfriend I'd
looked forward to and her family we'd
all get together and watch Wow so what a
great here's the thing is if that's the
bar just in general of what a great show
is mmm
one day maybe soon somebody will create
something even better yeah it might even
have anything to do with Game of Thrones
or whatever it could be a sci-fi thing
or something else but um I think by the
time I'm dead I'll see two or three
other things George is gonna be better
maybe I'm excited about I do though I do
like one of the things I really enjoyed
about the series that I that
from the beginning that really I knew
that this was something special is when
they killed Edie's dark you know
when they killed him I was like you
don't you don't do that on TV and that
opened up the world of like that
anything can happen and that's what made
to show great from the beginning so I do
agree with you I mean and you know we're
talking [ __ ] and it is a testament to
the creators that were so passionate
about the final season like it or not
it's because of what they did so yeah I
do give them credit for that and I want
to thank them for making a you know a
great show and having like you know even
you know what even was worse than that
that may got me cut that got me hooked
is when Joffrey showed sons are Ned's
head oh yeah on the thing yeah and how
just morbid and angry you were oh like
like you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] oh yeah
you know a character that we loved that
was I've never seen anything like Chuck
supposed to like creating a character
that I don't think I've hated a
character more than Joffrey it what but
then you Liz Ramsey I mean you think
that oh I hate Joffrey and then Ramsay
comes along you're like holy [ __ ] but
imagine if Ramses yeah imagine if Ramses
after everything he did he gets to die
with a rocks coming down on him that's
what I'm saying oh no [ __ ] like I'm
out right but that's why he got it good
eaten by dogs I know but you know what
I'll be honest
don't you love Cersei Lannister love her
know you yes you do you love is her
character oh yeah great character right
yeah yeah there is and she when I mean
love I don't mean love to hate I mean
love you loved her I mean I think that
she went through so much that's what I'm
saying yeah I agree that did that walk
of shame which was naked on the street
yeah when she first meets the mountain
yeah yeah I mean she went through her
own thing losing all her children yeah
and she was fighting for her kids the
whole time that's what I'm saying so you
know for me she snapped when her kid
killed himself
you know when the one though the last
King you know he jumped off the [ __ ]
roof this
she was like [ __ ] it I'll be queen I'm
only one that can do this [ __ ]
yeah or how heartbreaking was that when
Jamie is on that boat with his daughter
she comes out like I know you're my real
dad because she got poisoned by the
those girls in Dorne yeah and then she's
the riding up on the boat and Cersei's
on the coast and she realizes that
there's a casket or another kid is
another kid is dead she's going through
a lot a lot and don't make me feel sorry
for her you piece of [ __ ] don't know but
that's the thing it's like so you know
do we want her torch right at the end I
don't think so at first I wanted her
baby cut out of her stomach and then put
in a vat of acid I know a lot of things
do yeah you know what you're right right
but again that could have been have a
scene that's kind of talking about how
we're talking and then you know then
we're like okay
she went out peacefully you know she's
gone through a lot her father was a
tyrant her father was the worst you know
I mean but she said a guy would would
have crossbolt to kill Jamie and she
wanted them both dead
what think I would have succeeded yeah
but bran yeah but I think could it be
that she knew that bran wasn't gonna do
it too or I don't know man
liked it like that guys so wishy-washy
why would he be on the council because
that's all he ever wanted was Oberon is
to be like big time bran wanted his own
you know his own what's it called castle
or you know and good money and prestige
and he got all the same things that he
worked his ass off he [ __ ] protected
little Peter Dinklage during his journey
yeah when he fought for ya at the Vale
yeah yeah so he deserves that listen
dude um at the end of the day we're just
gonna go through a depression because I
was done and I love the show and here's
there's nothing like it either there's
nothing like I'm looking forward to
anything nothing
yeah it's so that's why we're doing this
because it's a big part of our lives
yes for sure yeah what a great great
great thing I know I know I totally
agree and when I talk to comedians like
Adam or
a guys like that who go a little woody
oh yeah [ __ ] like [ __ ] off
yeah Coco [ __ ] yourself [ __ ] yourself
you know you watch Breaking Bad you
would like it or not you don't mean you
watch this kind of [ __ ] you know this is
like just kind of anything that's like
moving the needle that it's making
people talk about it outside of it and
people you know
I feel chatty a part of that yeah but I
also feel bad now for the actors because
let's be honest it this will probably
never happen but the thing that gets me
up in the morning is maybe I'll get the
call today
yeah yeah right they got the call
already yeah that's done where I'm gonna
get the call let's hope it was lucrative
enough for them to though maybe maybe
it's not cuz it could be they can they
can always do conventions yeah oh my god
a man you can charge twenty bucks for a
headshot people wait in line but um
imagine being some of those actors it's
like no matter what Maisie Williams does
and I'm sure she'll have a great Mirza
aria oh right right right she'll always
be aria she'll always think to herself
yeah this is cool but it's not mmm
the same it to go from a show where the
whole world is watching is winning the
lottery yeah you know I've been in so
many I've done so many pilots you know
seven in my life
two on air I know to get on a show like
Game of Thrones is winning the lottery
you know how lucky are those actors how
about thinking you're on a show that's
gonna be something special and it still
gets cancelled you know I know I've you
know mine show just got cancelled last
week no I'm sorry to do that you didn't
say that earlier Bobby you know I love
you okay you're my you're my girl one of
my best friends in the whole wide world
you know that's why when you call me
about your [ __ ] uncle I was feeling
for you and the fact that you did that
on your podcast I did you listen I got a
joke I was just trying to teach my
people that listen to my podcast or you
are a new word the fact that you're
framing it that way is
what an [ __ ] you can be the new word
is tral I I bet you there's a t-shirt is
there a t-shirt coming maybe I I I want
10% what at rely is is the truth and lie
at one and so when I said that my
favorite uncle had died it was truth no
it's either a lie or it's not no no it's
a lie you can't be half pregnant that's
what that is okay you just [ __ ] you
lied
you know you lied you misled me with the
information you imply that your uncle
just died
that's the implication and you know it
you [ __ ] lied okay you were doing a
pop if you would have said to me hey man
I'm already doing a podcast right now I
can that can we just hold off because I
don't know if I could talk for another
hour and a half again you don't think I
wouldn't understood uh-huh yeah don't do
that [ __ ] again
I will I [ __ ] I [ __ ] will and
you're still gonna love me oh my god
that's me don't change me oh my god
alright okay I drove all the way over
here from century to century City this
is covert see whatever this is okay you
know so back up dude oh my god you're
such a you're a [ __ ] idiot I'm the
idiot yeah don't ever talk to me like
that again yeah you know what revenge is
best served cold okay I'm coming I'm
coming for you like the Hound we're
gonna be fighting on stairs yeah you're
definitely a mountain yeah and you're
definitely a [ __ ] monster underneath
a man's that's uhyou know Bulldogs are
cute okay we're if you're cute we're
both cute how about that
you're give it to me just give it to me
all right all right
this is Bobby Lee everybody so anyway um
let's I think the watchman looks
promising I feel I didn't like the movie
so I'm not a finger different I just I
know how we watched the movie actually
did you like it first and a half was
pretty cool then it became like oh I
know yeah yeah how about this have you
seen John wick all of them loved Jon
okay here's the thing though I have one
problem with John wick it's knowing that
John wick too
[Music]
and John wick three there's no time
between them it literally is right after
John wick - he's still limping from John
wick - and now he fights for another two
and a half hours yeah you said three
yeah good
oh I thought you said you saw it that's
a - oh you never seen three no oh I
don't want to talk about it I get done
oh you have to why I'll go with you I
want to go with you no but I also want
to see shutters shut I'm gonna know
what's it called what bright man Oh
bright burn yeah oh I saw it
Danko's that you told me - it's great
game cook but I brought you yeah yeah
yeah what me no why because it was just
at my house he knows what a [ __ ] you
are I know it was great the best way I
can describe right burn it's it's uh
it's the almond meet Logan in Smallville
yeah that's the best way they've drawn
it looks fun it's really spooky yeah the
kid is great the kid is a little
laughing I want to ask you about the
last thing which is um the third Star
Wars coming out now you saw the trailer
I'm Bobby Bobby I like I don't want to
watch like when they were at the casino
I wanted to leave already
I wanted to like I was like okay they
they're off the rails they've taken this
thing that I love you know what I mean
and they've ruined it and I don't want
to talk about it anymore you know me I'm
saying I don't want to watch this you
know Johnson together directed it right
there should be a trial yeah I'm not
kidding you we need to put them on trial
Senate hearings right like yeah it's
just like that the McCarthy here he's
gotta go yeah and I better be at that
yeah yeah yeah I mean oh you're we're in
the pan yeah and I have notes so can you
explain to me why okay how how when
somebody doesn't you know show any kind
of Jedi anything yeah and they're dead
in space like this
woo-wee and then they float back but we
don't know what's been happening with
Leia for the past 30 years in between
she could have been doing a little bit
of Jedi training you gotta show it
though yeah I agree because if they
don't show it we don't know it nobody
again like all of this societal [ __ ]
about like you know everything that's
going on and they're trying to show
parallels I'm like I don't need all that
[ __ ] just stick on message Star Wars
yeah so now they're gonna do this thing
again where I'm like first of all I
loved the ending of that movie though
when the last one when you know that
when you know what kylo Ren kills that
one guy that was a great villain why
kill him I thought it was a great
villain I like how he is talking and
moving and all that attitude right has a
lightsaber right here yeah right uh-huh
this dude is supposed to be a Jedi
himself I don't know I know but that
we're trying to show that like cuz Kyle
he was in kylos head and he was like
Kyle must have been concentrating like
I'm gonna kill my enemy he knew what he
was doing he was like right but he knew
that there was a light set right here
right he would that would have never
happened
no nobody turn his power I agree I agree
did that that wouldn't happen yes so
that but but and I don't know like this
this thing they're showing where he's
still trying to kill her
and then why run her over with the
spaceship but if you look at the new
trailer - you see dead land oh yeah yeah
yeah like did you see how old he looked
and he's like Brian he was like three
strokes he should just have a colt 45 in
his hand right
I mean well they all look terrible
Princess Leia look terrible you know
yeah our IP but she didn't look great
you know I mean she didn't look great I
thought that um look Luke did looked
okay I look good yeah but um but yeah
but you will watch the third one I'm
gonna have to you have just a complaint
right but you know what here's another
thing Rian Johnson's out and it's JJ
Abrams yeah but he I know he knows like
well he was good with Star Wars I'm a
Star Trek I thought the first couple of
star tracks were pretty good I like yeah
he did the first one the first the first
and didn't do the second one but the
first one was great I like it on its
head and made like they they found a way
to wipeout
hitting was amazing on that I think that
it was dead on arm I think that he you
know he did lost oh that's true yes so
anka dude Celtic guy yeah he's very
challenged but he's gonna but the reason
why hello imagine though if you the unit
you can't wipe it out like you can't be
like hey can we just start over because
I don't want you have to continue
somebody's [ __ ] so what did you like
about the Star Wars do here's here's who
got ripped apart is that Asian check
yeah what do you know her name no idea
but what I do know is is that she had to
delete her Instagram and her Twitter and
stop because people were ripping her
apart
she was like to Jar Jar Binks of this
movie can I just say this though is is
that when you read for something and
they go you got it yeah and then you
show up on a set like Star Wars huh
you're gonna do whatever they wrote yeah
first of all you're gonna take the job
no one's ever gonna go Isis you're an
unknown now Rian Johnson's now yeah
right I know she's gonna be like yeah
right yeah they you're gonna go to
wherever Iceland where they're shooting
this is gonna be you think it's gonna be
life-changing right it's Star Wars you
know right and then you're and then your
seat I'm sorry and then you show up and
you're and um you know you're doing what
they wrote and after every take they're
like yeah they give you notes yeah a
little faster or we didn't really feel
when you say this line you know and then
you do exactly what they tell you to do
and then you go to the premiere you're
excited here and then all of a sudden
you're to blame right for a bad movie
and right like it's like no I open all
around bad movie by the way and then you
can if she's just a portion of it and
she's gonna Lynch right it's it's not
fair yeah it wasn't fair at all
and I think and and I know that because
I've been reading reviews on YouTube
right
this guy named Dishonored wolf you know
mean
he calls her fat asian [ __ ] in his
review oh my god like really harsh I
know it's a white dude saying it because
you can tell but it's [ __ ] terrible
especially the one that's copy written
for your mom you know what I mean
come on dude you do that kinda [ __ ] to
me all the time but I agree with you
getting back on message that it's like
it's not fair that they made a terrible
movie with a lot of bad choices cuz to
me it's not her fault
but the choice of having that character
in the movie was the bad choice it's not
her fault that she did exactly what they
wanted to do and it's like why have this
but you know she can also do this hey at
the table read this casino thing right
it doesn't really kind of work out she
can't say [ __ ] about she has to read it
and they're gonna go what do you think
and she has no say I don't even ask her
well even if they did though she has to
go it's amazing yeah yeah no it just she
reads it she shows up she does the best
she can and she's acting you actually
very good at it yeah if you watch the
six great heard the girl playing her
sister who died yeah yeah that was great
that was great all that stuff's great
but it's like the movie just went off
the rails so yeah yes it's all Ryan Jon
you can rip on tryin John yeah cuz it's
his fault
but do you know what this is the nature
of what the business that we're in now
with the internet and like YouTube and
all this [ __ ] for somebody I don't like
that guy to just to go online look even
us we're trashing Game of Thrones and
we're going back and forth of what we
like about it but it's like for the guy
to go on the internet and call somebody
that it's just like come on man we would
never rip on a character on Game of
Thrones right there's an actual actor
whatever doctor yeah that's what they
did with her that's terrible her Nate
using her name and one
it's not even what like you said the
main point here is that it's not her
fault that they wrote this she did the
best she could in that situation and
then like what are you supposed to do at
the end of the day exactly you know so I
agree with you men but um so kudos to
her I will watch the throw one I guess
we have to let me ask you this because
we haven't talked about it did we talk
about hereditary yet no we didn't
actually all right let's what I want
just this let's recap yeah this yeah
honor hereditary now honestly I think we
did talk about hereditary on another
thing but go ahead we can we did it yeah
I just want to say honestly you saw it
yeah I did what's not on a point what
did you think oh I thought it was great
you do honest no no yeah for real I love
that I love that kind of stuff I love
that slow burn yeah yeah and I loved it
like those scary moments like I love
scary [ __ ] where like you know you know
you don't like like like just a woman in
the corn market that was so like they he
just cuts to a wide yeah and you don't
even know what you're supposed to be
looking at but then you see it yeah
right burns like that by the way oh
really yeah
my parents got moments like that where
you just like oh [ __ ] what would you
really so it's like I can't wait I enjoy
hereditary I haven't there's a bunch of
scary movies that just came out that I
haven't even seen yet have you seen
anything new scary movie no but are that
guy that did hereditary has a new movie
that's on his trailers out what's it
what's it called summer's day or
something oh oh yes some summer
something under something my girl we got
a we haven't been to a good nice scary
movie together on a while 7 o'clock I
know we gotta go I have to eat I mean
you know that you want to get something
where we'll figure it out after wanna
see what time I'd show us two more times
your show I don't even have a show
tonight
why well excited I got a show tomorrow
and my mom's coming back Saturday
you know like 4 years ago it's like
Oliver Hudson you know he was Oliver
Hudson's Kate Hudson's brother mm-hmm
he was the lead of the show that I got
cancelled mmm and he just texted me I
love you oh well you know I'm never
gonna work you always think that we both
do show gets canceled to some kind of we
think well that's it is that the thing
is that this this one uh-huh was
yeah Oh easy Bobby they're all easy
they're not to get no no no I'm see the
get oh right right because you know what
that's a testament to the why you've
made it man you're in the game bro stop
it it's gonna happen again you know a
lot of people people gonna be like we
women you know we want a funny dude and
they're gonna get you relaxed no they'll
go to Ken Jeong first they'll go to like
nine other people anyway it's really
good to have you on have me on your
rockin Rick and Rick and with Rickon
riffing with Richie Richie I hate you so
much but Bobby honestly though thank you
for coming do this again we have to you
and Bobby need to people keep saying
about you and Bobby Steve cookies are my
favorite Lee Steve and Bobby you both
need to come on again you keep doing our
movie thing we will every [ __ ] day
somebody sitting me up where's Stevie
well why didn't Steve come today oh you
know I didn't hit him up you know and
you you know why Steve didn't come today
so don't you know the Lee brothers are
always in turmoil you know I got to be
in the [ __ ] middle all the time we're
not in turmoil you were in Tom why not
return when I'm turmoil you know I
called him yesterday my brother and I
said to him no one in your life would
take a bullet for you
except for me am i you would Steve you
wouldn't take a bullet for Steve you
don't know that and you think I'm gonna
put Steve in front of the you know all
right so um let me see what tell my spot
is you don't have a spot tonight no I
don't have a spot tonight but uh can we
can we do this after could you like put
your I just need to know this is
[ __ ] anyways guys this has been
Bobby Lee
this is riff from with Griffin
appreciate everybody's love the support
please hit that subscribe today today's
Thursday
hit just subscribe know there's enough
it's got a 9:30 spot tonight but this
will be like weeks ago when
but this is my good friend in the world
my brother I'm gonna go now we gotta go
now
okay all right he's got to go Bob Bob
he's got to go thanks for uh thanks for
being on Bobby all right
[Music]